for people in the village of nashel
sixty-year-old anastas debajo is a hero
he brought electricity to the small
hamlet three months ago when he
supervised the building of a small
hydroelectric power facility now debajo
has come back to Nashville to check that
everything's working properly he
constructed the plant with men from the
village here at the water source was
where it all began with them right now
to start my wife thought I was crazy I
mean I the neighbors all told her
divorced that guy your husband has lost
his mind well when you Quinlan with us
but then they saw that I could earn
money from hydroelectric power we don't
miss it her neighbors suddenly came to
me and they wanted to buy electricity
but that would be totally
the most amazing thing about the story
is that Tuberville taught himself how to
build a generator to convert the water
power into electricity the self-taught
engineer spent years learning about the
technology so he could give his nine
children electric light in their home
village so quick des amis on yet Izzy we
were poor and we wanted to earn money
and get electricity for our village
what's up little Jimmy quite a different
tale we had nothing other than diesel
generators and petroleum yeah like
Milton anaconda so I thought I don't why
shouldn't we use the power of water it
sounds we do know that can make our
lives easier shot see our economy number
on da magana no no yeah we're optimizing
200 households in nashel now enjoy
electricity that amounts to a revolution
in a remote region beyond the
electricity grid where people live from
what they grow in fields or gather from
the forest small-scale initiatives need
support if they're to succeed and the
Rwandan ministry of the environment
helps Tavares project become reality Eve
to you she may advise taba Hall on how
to create hydropower plants in villages
Rwanda says it plans to increase its
support for renewable energy sources
they have to protect environment you
know when you are using renewable energy
like this hydro power plant we are
reducing dependence on fossil fuel
petrol and that's why we encourage this
kind of project so we are here to see if
honest has this kind of project he has
made for this village can qualify for
carbon market there's a way they can get
carbon credit so that to finance this
project
in the past there were no small
businesses in the villages now young
people like Eric moon Genizah see a
future here at 20 he's opened up a
barber shop
but Ibaka used to use diesel generators
but that was loud and expensive it also
stank everything's better using
hydropower I've hired assistance to cope
with demand sometimes customers even
have to stand in line to get him new
king named bianca the land of a Thousand
Hills as Rwanda is known has been
partially deforested to ye shi mei is
also traveling around the country to see
what can be done about it and improve
people's lives one of his success
stories has come to the village of
Mandela outside the ruined and capital
kigali many of the residents are women
who narrowly escaped ethnic genocide 20
years ago the wall after village full of
widows and orphans would you move to you
she may introduce them to the Wonder bag
it's an insulated cooking bag that means
the women can cook in the morning and
put the pots in the bag it conserves
heat so the food continues to simmer
when mooga manasa returns home from the
field at midday lunch is ready it saves
both work and resources it used to be
very difficult to find firewood with the
Wonder bag we save a lot of energy now I
can cook for a week with the same amount
of wood I use in a single day that means
I can make something warm for the
children every day hey get the kid Mucha
d+ copiously lies the average price of
the Wonder bag is 25 US dollars well
beyond these women's means to you she
may and his ministry are trying to get
ruined in villages to save enough energy
for the country to be able to sell
carbon emission credits carbon finance
helps to cut down the price you know
these one bag are really expensive for
these people to afford but through
carbon finance carbon money comes to sub
dies the this wonder back so that people
can access them free of charge back to
an estas Navarro in nashel he's looking
forward to returning to his home village
about 300 kilometres away he also has a
dream for the whole of Rwanda is lasagna
no wound it now goes I design old now
I'd like to teach the next generation
how to build small hydroelectric power
plants look what you done once a bit i
get like them to continue my work you
miss all the water power that rwanda has
its disposal when i call ya Kanye you
will create unique way before anastas
terbaru sets off back home he takes one
last look and one last picture of the
power plant that way he can show other
villages how easily the facility works